ja ich begrüße sie zur 14 sitzung
unseres seminars über theorien der
existenz und es geht heute um niemand
geringeren als um aristoteles sie wir
sind alle aristoteles ist ein ganz
bedeutender denker der antike mit
plattform zusammen die bedeutendste und
bevor wir aber auf seine und reagiere
genauer gesagt auf seine metallphysik
zwar es jedenfalls sein hauptwerk
eingehen will ich ihnen auch ganz kurze
zusammenfassung geben darüber was in der
letzten sitzung gemacht hatten
sie nennt sich wir hatten dort uns mit
platon beschäftigt das ist dieser nette
herr hier
wir haben verschiedene ansichten von ihm
hier gibt es noch eines und gemälde
und was gibt's zu platon zusagen platon
hat ein ganz interessantes leben auch
gehabt er ist zum beispiel entführt
worden von seeräubern und versklavt
worden und so wurde er wieder gerettet
sehr spannend und dazu gibt es ein
platon handbuch herausgegeben von
christoph horn jörn müller und joachim
söder und dieses platon handbuch können
sie sich als studierende der tu und
bestimmt auch von anderen universitäten
kostenlosen ganz legal über ihre online
bibliothek ausleihen nicht nur ausleihen
sondern sogar herunterladen als pdf
datei kann ich ihnen sehr empfehlen
und jetzt möchte ich noch mal ganz kurz
auf diesen unterschied zwischen
metaphysiker generals und metaphysik ein
spezialist eingehen also das ist ja
immer die frage was ist jetzt der
unterschied zwischen ontologie und
metaphysik wenn es ein seminarist über
die frage was existiert was ist existenz
müssen wir auch zugleich die frage
beantworten was eigentlich und
tolerieren was eigentlich metaphysik ist
und diese unterscheidung die ich mir
jetzt vorstellen die es eigentlich sehr
zentral auch noch heutzutage diese
metaphysiker general ist also die
generelle
die metaphysik die wird heutzutage als
anthologie gefasst das ist also die
wissenschaft die sich mit den kategorien
den allgemeinen kategorien des seienden
desjenigen was existiert befasst das ist
die ontologie und die metaphysiker
spezielles ist die wissenschaft die sich
mit speziellen seiten befasst also mit
der theologie mit der psychologin
kosmologie das heißt auch mit
entsprechenden gegenständen in der
rationalen theologie ist dass gott der
rationalen psychologie seele und der
rationalen kosmologie ist es die wild
also ganz konkrete gegenstände die aber
trotzdem sehr allgemein sind die werden
in der metaphysik spezialist wir haben
heutzutage sagen wir dann das ist die
metaphysik die diese themen befasst als
die recht speziellen gravierenden themen
und direkt allgemeinen gravierenden
themen das ist die ontologie aber auch
darüber kann man diskutieren
so jetzt hatten wir dann gesehen bei
platt und findet sich so eine
unterscheidung zwischen zwei welten
das ist jetzt ja allgemein gesagt das
betrifft diese frage was scientist
unterscheidet er in einem zitat aus dem
haider und was ich in den letzten
sitzungen präsentiert hatte er
unterscheidet zwischen einer sichtbaren
welt das ist die welt in der die
gegenstände vergänglich sind und in
geringerem maße serien sind ich hatte
gesagt platt und hat so eine
komparatistik ontologie also für ihn
existiert nicht alles im selben grad
oder mars und eine unsichtbare welt
das ist also die welt in der die
unvergänglichen gegenstände existieren
und das sind zum beispiel mathematische
gegenstände also zahlen die sind nicht
vergänglich wie es jetzt zum beispiel
konkrete bäume sind ohne konkrete tische
und dazu gehören natürlich vor allem
auch die ideen das ist die unsichtbare
welt unsichtbar meint hier eben nicht
mit unseren sinnesorganen mit unserem
körperlichen sinnesorgan also nicht zu
hören nicht zu sehen und so weiter auch
wenn traten dann davon spricht dass
diese gegenstände unsichtbaren welt auch
mit bestimmten sinnesorganen erfasst
werden können er nimmt das dann zum
beispiel den news
und dennoch es ist also die vernunft und
dieses vermögen hat auch was von einem
sinnlichen erkenntnisvermögen natürlich
einen höheren erkenntnisvermögen das ist
so eine grundsätzliche unterscheidung
die sie jetzt noch recht schematisch
hier
dazwischen gibt es natürlich noch
verschiedene zwischenstufen und das
betrifft diese comparatives tisch und
theologie nicht alles existiert im
selben grad
und was jetzt wie existiert das ist ja
unser seminar frage darüber gibt platon
sogenanntes liegen gleichnis nähere
auskunft und das möchte ich ihnen auch
noch mal zeigen die quelle ist hier der
dtv atlas philosophie kann ich auch
empfehlen ist auch wenn man jetzt
philosophie studiert hat noch schon ein
bisschen weiter ist immer noch sehr
hilfreich weil es gute grafiken gute
veranschaulichung bringt die hatten wir
gesehen ganz oben in diesem gleichnis
dass es die gleichen ebene also diese
linke spalte ist die gleichnis ebene und
die rechte spalte ist die philosophische
ebene also die eigentliche ebene der
idee des guten entspricht die sonne in
diesem gleichnis und das ist dann auch
immer die ontologie also diese spalte
gibt hier diejenigen gegenstände andere
existenzen an die platon annimmt und wir
hatten gesehen die ideen existieren im
eigentlichen sinn im höchsten grade weil
sie unvergänglich sind weil sie
letztendlich die definition die begriffe
auch der sinnlichen gegenstände
enthalten und nicht nur das sie sind der
erkenntnis grund also nur durch die
ideen können wir die konkreten
gegenstände erkennen
und mehr noch nur durch die ideen
existieren diese konkreten gegenstände
wie jetzt zum beispiel eben bäume oder
vasen in der welt also diese doppelung
von erkenntnis grund die dänen sind die
erkenntnis grund und sie sind der
science grund der weltlichen gegenstände
die da eben vergänglich sind und die der
sichtbaren welt zu gehören und
dazwischen gibt es eben noch andré
entitäten sagt man auch also gegenstände
zum beispiel mathematische gegenstände
das wären jetzt zum beispiel zahlen in
der
mutig die zahl fünf sagt barth und die
existiert irgendwie jetzt ist natürlich
die frage wie existiert die zahl fünf
sie existiert ja wohl nicht in raum und
zeit ich kann sie nicht anfassen ich
kann sie nicht riechen aber warum könnte
jetzt platt und sagen dass sie existiert
na gut wir können mit der zahl fünf eben
was tun wir können mit ihr operieren
können mit ihr rechnen und die zahl 5
ist unabhängig jetzt davon ob ich jetzt
fünf birnen oder fünf habe sie ist davon
losgelöst
wir können uns auf sie beziehen wenn wir
denken rechnen
und deswegen gibt es gewisse gründe
dafür diese these wird heutzutage noch
von manchen mathematiker vertreten dass
zahlen auch existieren aber eben auf
eine andere weise wie er es jetzt zum
beispiel vasen tun die in dieser höhle
diesem höhlengleichnis stehen wie
existieren zahlen spannende frage ja
nicht räumlich nicht zeitlich wir können
sie nicht riechen wir können sie nicht
schmecken wir können sie nicht hören
aber wir können uns auf sie kognitiv
beziehen und einen begriff davon machen
das ist zum beispiel einen merkmalen
darüber könnten wir uns noch lange
sprechen ist jetzt nicht unser ziel
und ein weiterer gegenstand sind zum
beispiel winkel oder auch formen
geometrische formen dreiecke sind ja
auch ideelle gegenstände in der
wirklichen welt der sichtbaren welt ich
habe jetzt fast schon was falsches nach
platon gesagt wird die wirkliche welt
ist die welche ideen die unwirkliche
welt ist eigentlich die die wir heute
als die wirkliche welt ansehen insofern
als eben die gegenstände in dieser
sichtbaren welt weniger seien sind als
es die ideen sind an dem sie teilhaben
jetzt sagt platen was ganz interessantes
diese mathematischen gegenstände die
existieren in geringerem maße als es die
ideen tun das kann man sich fragen woher
kommt das der grund ist der
mathematische gegenstände die sind immer
noch abhängig oder mathematik ist immer
noch abhängig von gewissen grundsätzen
die sie selbst nicht mehr hinterfragt
das sind zum beispiel axiome das gibt es
in der geometrie von euklid gibt es
besondere grundsätze auf den die
athletische geometrie
passiert zum beispiel das parallelen
aktion und die selbst werden nicht
hinterfragt die werden als wahl
vorausgesetzt auf den werden dann die
verschiedenen arithmetischen der
geometrischen theorien auf darauf
errichtet aber diese aktionen können
selbst nicht wieder eingeholt werden
und das ist so platter der grund warum
die mathematik und ihre gegenstände
nicht so seien sind nicht zum hohen maße
sein sind wie es die gegenstände die
sind die die ideen darstellen weil die
ideen selbst der letzte grund sind man
kann da nicht noch weiter fragen die
ideen setzen nichts heraus was sie
selbst nicht erklären können sondern
ideen sind die erklärung ihrer selbst
die ideen sind die letzten erklärungen
der dinge die an ihn teilhaben als sie
sind sein der urgrund theater spricht
auch von arche also diese ist es diese
diese uhr grund im sinne des erkenntnis
grundes und des seins grundes dann gibt
es noch andere gegenstände geben die die
lebewesen und und auch sonstige
gegenstände und dann noch die bilder von
ihnen als bloße abbilder auch
täuschungen und diese verbreitung noch
weniger existenz als existent als ist
diese weltlichen gegenstände sind jetzt
amazone gewisse skala an existenz formen
die immer weiter zunehmen von unten nach
oben
wir hatten davon gesprochen das klar
schon auch dem nichts einen gewissen
raum einräumen muss und dass nichts
würde sozusagen rausfallen aus diesem
linie gleichen ist es wäre hier ganz
unten
das wäre also knapp unter der täuschung
dem spiegelbild dem zerrbild also diesem
schatten hier also darunter wäre das
nicht der schatten existiert ein
bisschen mehr als das nichts
obwohl er uns täuscht und darin eben
nach platon weniger existenz ist als die
wahl von der der schatten eben der
schatten ist das ist diese eine
randbereich des nicht oder gibt es auch
den anderen randbereich der es dann da
oben beziehungsweise hier ist die idee
des guten
und da sagt platon dass die idee des
guten
jenseits des seiten steht wie ist das zu
verstehen existiert sie überhaupt wenn
sie jenseits das sein dann ist da geht
es ganz verschiedene interpretationen
dazu mir persönlich scheint am
überzeugendsten zu sein dass man sagt
die idee des guten die gibt allem sein
denn vor allem den ideen die einheit
noch mal also die ist die einheit aller
ideen wenn man jetzt verschiedene ideen
hat mehrere ideen hat kann man sich ja
immer noch zu recht fragen ja aber was
ist denn der grund der ideen warum gibt
es denn so viele ideen was ist die
einheit dieser idee und diese einheit
der ideen wäre eben mal platt und die
idee des guten
und sie würde dadurch eben auch dass
sein übersteigen als ist es erst möglich
gemacht wir hatten es in dem seminar
diskutiert man könnte das möglich machen
auch im sinne von sinn verstehen dass
das ganze bedeutung bekommt sinnvoll ist
zweckmäßig verfasst ist solche dinge
kann man hier diese idee des guten zu
schreiben
natürlich kann man sich fragen gibt es
nach plan auch eine idee des bösen oder
des schlechten
das ist die frage nach platin er nicht
weil es ja nicht existiert es wäre ihr
hier in diesen unteren bereich zu suchen
aber das ist auch eine spannende frage
kann man viel drüber diskutieren
und dieser weg von den ideen zur idee
des guten wäre die transzendenz die
besteigung und der weg von der idee des
guten zurück zu den natürlichen dingen
zu den ideen wäre das transzendentale
also die bedingung der möglichkeit diese
anderen existenzen
das ist so meine interpretation aber da
gibt es ganz viele reputations
möglichkeiten
das ist alles sehr zentral weil sich
alle nach platonischen denke irgendwie
immer darauf beziehen auf dieses liegen
gleich nen ist so und jetzt kommen wir
eben zu einem dieser nach platonischen
denker und das ist niemand geringeres
als dieser herr hier das ist aristoteles
verschiedenen perspektiven und wie sie
sehen er ist ein bisschen jünger als
plattform und er war schüler von
plattformen
und auch hierzu möchte ich ihnen was
empfehlen nämlich ganz analog zum platon
handbuch das aristoteles handbuch
herausgegeben von christoph raab der
lehrt hier an der lmu münchen und auch
dieses aristoteles handbuch können sie
sich kostenlos und ganz legal als pdf
datei über den opa katalog herunterladen
ich hatte ihn dazu daraus ein auszug
geschickten der nach der letzten sitzung
kann ich sehr empfehlen
ok und jetzt gehören auf die leitfragen
der heutigen sitzung ein also in welchen
verschiedenen bedeutungen versteht
aristoteles das wort sein in seiner
metaphysik
eine weitere frage ist wie verhält sich
aristoteles ontologie zu derjenigen
platons wir hatten jetzt platt und schon
ein bisschen besser kennengelernt jetzt
können wir uns fragen wie verhalten sich
zueinander
eine weitere frage worin liegen die
probleme der aristotelischen anthologie
die auf platons ontologie hat gewisse
probleme und dann die vielleicht sogar
wichtigste frage auf die ich auch gleich
noch mal einkommen eingehen werde was
bedeutet nach aristoteles eigentlich
metaphysik wir hatten jetzt schon
diskutiert was metaphysik alles heißen
kann wir haben es unterschiede von
theologie wir sind auf die metaphysiker
spezialist und die metaphysik general
ist eingegangen
aber jetzt wollen wir mal schauen was
aristoteles selbst zu diesem terminus
sagt also zur bedeutung des wortes
metaphysik das ist auch ganz wichtig
dass man das mal gehört hat das kommt
vom altgriechischen metaphysiker also
das was du das ist das theater heißt
hinter oder nach das was hinter oder
nach der physik ist oder steht das ist
also eine wörtliche übersetzung und das
ist zunächst nur eine ordnungsbusse oder
bibliographische beschreibung dieses
werks was man heute bei aristoteles
metaphysik nennt gewesen
das heißt eine bibliografie oder ein
schreiber der antike das war der an tony
cross von rhodos sagt man
der hat eben dieses werk was heute mit
der physik genannt wird von aristoteles
nach seiner physik im regal oder eben wo
auch immer in der ausgabe eingeordnet
also dieses hinter oder nach ist jetzt
so zu verstehen wie in diesem
bücherregal hier bei mir also da ist
jetzt die physik und dann ist da die
metaphysik
also es kommt einfach danach dieses
metall ist danach das ist einfach so
eine ordnung logische beschreibung des
bibliographischen ist später wurde dann
aus dieser bloßen ordnungs logik im
regal eine philosophische bedeutung da
wurde dann dieses metall im sinne des
über physischen des des transzendenten
verstanden hat natürlich auch seinen
grund in dieser bibliographischen
ordnung der andronicus von roters wird
nicht ohne grund die metaphysik nach der
physik eingeordnet haben er hat sich da
mal was gedacht und insofern hängen
diese bibliographische ordnung die
philosophische ordnung durchaus
miteinander zusammen
also heutzutage bedeutet eben metaphysik
dasjenige was über die physik hinausgeht
mit platon gesprochen zb die ideen ja
warum weil die ideen eben nach platon
nicht mehr der veränderungen unterliegen
und die physik ist geben nach glatten
und auch nach aristoteles genau das was
im werden und vergehen begriffen ist
also praktisch die sichtbare welt wo wir
keine ganz feste identität haben wo
alles vergeht und irgendwie bisschen
schwammig ist nur was mangelhaft auch
sein kann dass es das physikalische das
physische das körperliche das
vergängliche und das über physische wäre
eben die macht das was nicht vergänglich
ist also zum beispiel die zahlen aber
eben vor allem die ideen nach platon und
jetzt wollen wir eben mal schauen was
ist jetzt für aristoteles das was nach
der physik kommt hat eine für sie
geschrieben so heißt dieses werk
wo er eben die körper beschreibt die
lebendigen körper die tiere die
fortpflanzung und so weiter und so fort
die bewegung die organe und das
interessiert uns nicht das interessiert
jetzt das was eben noch grundsätzlicher
ist was nicht vergänglich ist
und das hat alles total ist auch sehr
interessiert und bezüglich dieser frage
rückt die frage ins zentrum was
eigentlich das eine ist die frage nach
der existenz die frage welche vor alters
so gut wie jetzt und immer aufgeworfen
und gegenstand des zweifels ist ist die
frage was das sein der zweifel ist jetzt
hier von diesem übersetzer vielleicht
ein bisschen ungünstig gewählt und
müsste vielleicht sagen der überprüfung
und des nachfrage ist ich vermute mal
dass das dass griechisches cobain ist
also dass das als die skepsis hängt
damit zusammen aber es ist das genau
ansehen das prüfen und das ist auch die
frage die uns in diesem seminar befasst
irgendwas das seien die ist und das sagt
alles total es hier dieser metaphysik im
siebten buch und hier sehen sie immer
die sogenannte becker situation nach dem
herrn becker so zitieren sie dann immer
aristoteles mit so einer zahl und einem
buchstaben und dann den zeilen nur dass
sie das hat die hausarbeit auch wissen
ok jetzt will ich ein paar weitere
zitate noch von aristoteles aus dieser
metaphysik vorlesen und das wird
ziemlich konkret obwohl es trotzdem noch
immer abstraktes der sagt es gibt eine
wissenschaft welche das seiende als sein
dass untersucht und das demselben
ansicht zu kommen diese wissenschaft ist
mit keiner der einzelnen wissenschaften
identisch denn keine der übrigen
wissenschaften handelt allgemein vom
sein denn als sein denn sondern sie
grenzen sich einen teil der seinen ab
und untersuchen tiefe diesen sich
ergebenden bestimmungen wie zb die
mathematischen wissenschaften in dem wir
nur die prinzipien und höchsten ursachen
untersuchen ist offenbar dass diese
notwendig ursachen einer gewissen natur
an
sein müssen also jetzt wollen wir
schauen was damit genau gemeint ist es
immer noch sehr abstrakt sagt noch mal
ein bisschen was jetzt ist das beispiel
die mathematik denn wie die zahl als
zahl besondere eigenschaften hat zum
beispiel ungerath haid und grad haid
verhältnis und gleichheit übermaß und
mangel was den zahlen sowohl an sich als
in beziehung auf einen dazu kommt und
ebenso das solide das unbewegte und das
bewegte das schwerelose und das schwere
andere eigenschaften hat ebenso hat auch
das seite als solches gewisse
eigentümliche merkmal und sie sind es
hinsichtlich deren der philosoph und die
philosophin die wahrheit zu erforschen
hat also es geht um die gewissen
eigentümlichen merkmale nicht irgendwie
eines beweglichen gegenstandes nicht
irgendwie der mathematik einer zahl oder
der physik sondern um die eigentümlichen
merkmale nichts geringeren als den sein
denn selbst und das ist die frage der
und theologie oder mit der anderen
technologie der metaphysik general ist
so und jetzt schauen wir uns mal hier
diesen dieses beispiel an
sie müssen sich also vorstellen das ist
jetzt ein kuchen man könnte den einen
science kuchen nennen
also das ist alles was es gibt das ist
diese kuchen diese kreis und die
speziellen wissenschaften wie die physik
die physiker die mathematik und die
psychologie oder auch die biologie
können sie beliebig viele abschnitte nur
ein zeichen die schneiden sich einen
teil des sein denn heraus und betrachten
ihn unter einer bestimmten hinsicht also
das sei insofern es mathematisch ist die
physik der seite insofern ist nach der
antiken lehre bewegliche dem werden und
vergehen unterworfen ist die psychologie
das seien die insofern ist seelisch ist
die biologie das sei insofern es lebt
und so weiter und sofort können sie
eigene gedanken zu machen und jetzt
fragt aber die philosophiere die
metaphysik nicht nachdem seinen insofern
es etwas anderes ist etwas
lebendig ist sondern nachdem sein denn
insofern es zeit ist all das seien die
als sein dass alles toten entspricht
riege von hell- und dh das sei insofern
ist existiert das sein die als sein dass
das heißt man könnte sagen die die
metaphysik hat eigentlich diesen kreis
also diese kreisbahn hierzu geben stimmt
nicht solche science kuchenstücke soll
den science randhir so könnte man sich
das ganze vorstellen
ja also das ist ein sehr ambitioniertes
unternehmen der metaphysik ja das ist
also eine universal wissenschaft die
eben die ganz basalen bestimmungen des
wenigen trifft was da auf der welt
existieren und jetzt kennt aristotle ist
ein paar kategorien wir sind das letzte
mal schon drauf eingegangen ist ein
bisschen als und platter und gegen und
seine bestimmung des 1 das sind die
bekannten zehn kategorien von
aristoteles das ist ganz wichtig
aristoteles hat mit kategorien schrift
verfasst und daraus sind jetzt diese
einzelnen kategorien entnommen ich gebe
auch immer ein beispiel also eine die
erste kategorie ist die substanz des die
wichtigste das ding zb ist das pferd
man kann nach der substanz immer fragen
wer oder was als es die subjekt stelle
im satz aristoteles verwendet die
kategorien sehr analog zu unseren kreis
unserer sprache zum satzbau also eben
das satz glied ja das ist hier das
entscheidende
das ist praktisch das subjekt das
subjekt stelle
wer das pferd dann ist die quantität ist
eine weitere kategorie also das pferd
wiegt eine tonne also wieviel napoleon
ist es das griechische wie viel die
qualität wie ist das pferd das pferd ist
schwarz oder schnell oder relation das
pferd wiegt zwölf mal so viel wie ich
wo ort auf der wiese das pferd steht auf
der wiese weitere punkt weitere
kategorie wann zeit vor einem jahr stand
das pferd auf einer wiese dann die lage
zustand es steht ein weiterer zustand
wäre es liegt oder oder so haben es hat
einen sattel und es tun wirken es frisst
von der weite und zum schluss das leiden
neben dem pferd werden die spuren
gegeben
oder es wird von einer mücke gestochen